today for our daily cancellation we're
going to cancel body shaming not the
thing itself
uh not the shaming but rather the focus
on it the hysteria over it
the claims made about it that's what
we're canceling
and just for example we'll start we'll
start with this um you know and this
year you know it's been a chaotic parade
of major news stories one after the
other
perhaps none have been quite as
significant though as the news that made
headlines across the media landscape
this week
you no doubt have probably already heard
pop singer billy eilish
was body shamed this is a big deal
you're supposed to care about this sort
of thing though nobody
is sure exactly why trumpet blast
resounded alerting the whole internet to
the incident which
quickly became a national crisis fox
news says billy eilish claps back at
body shamers
yahoo reports billy eilish responds to
body shamers
msn tells us billy eilish body shaming
video goes viral as singer responds to
trolls
the independent l e t cosmopolitan other
publications had their own reports
buzzfeed as always published the
definitive essay on the topic in a post
titled
grown ass adults please stop body
shaming billy eilish
that article written by pulitzer
candidate ryan shockett
informs us that a recent photo of the
singer walking down the street wearing a
tank top
and shorts and sandals with socks set
off a wave of critiques commentary and
discussion
now by the way as an avid sock and
sandal wearer myself
unapologetically so i would hope that
the photo would if anything
um help to normalize the sock and sandal
community
but instead of discussing the advantages
of footwear that allows you to probably
show off your favorite socks instead of
hiding them inside dreary and boring
shoes
it seems that the discussion in this
case took a negative turn
the body shamers were out in force a
whole wave of them
part of the body shaming epidemic as it
has been called
all of them set on ruthlessly mocking
and belittling billy eilish one of the
body shaming tweets from an anonymous
user said
in 10 months billy eilish has developed
a mid-30s wine mom body
another body shamer said wait there
wasn't another one that was pretty much
it
there was precisely one negative comment
from some guy
in england who goes by the handle game
snosh
and many thousands of comments from
people mercilessly scolding him for his
rude behavior
while keeping compliments and accolades
on eilish now i have not counted all of
them but i would say i would guess that
there's probably a 100 000 to 1 ratio
of positive to negative comments and
that's probably a significant
understatement
also the people saying nice things
include powerful media platforms
fellow celebrities the people saying
mean things include
gamesnosh though in fairness if i
scoured twitter i'm sure i could
probably find up to a dozen
you know accounts with anime avatars
also insulting heilish
in hopes of leeching some of the
attention from the dastardly gangster
but all told i don't think there's a
real problem here
lots and lots of people are saying very
nice things about a woman who walked
down the street
wearing shorts one dude said not nice
things
this is not exactly pearl harbor in
terms of national significance
true eilish has been targeted by shamers
before or so i'm told
she's spoken out about the body shaming
and issued many eloquent clapbacks over
the years but again
a look at her instagram account or music
videos on youtube
reveal a very near unanimous agreement
that eilish is beautiful amazing
brilliant
she also won six grammy awards this year
which should serve i would think as a
nice self-esteem boost
but even with millions of adoring fans
and legions of
of internet warriors ready to leap into
action to rip anyone to shreds should
they utter the mildest insult about her
looks music or anything else
we're still told that there's a real
problem even a newsworthy problem
of billy eilish being body shamed
it's not just billy eilish to hear the
media tell it you would think that we
live in a culture
utterly beset by body shaming great
effort is made to denounce body shaming
counteract body shaming
raise awareness about body shaming
eradicate body shaming
and the body shaming problem has
attracted such intense focus that it's
even been broken down
into sub categories we've gotten very
specific with it
there's the infamous fat shaming the
slightly less infamous skinny shaming
plus there's tall shaming short shaming
hair shaming bald shaming skin shaming
teeth shaming foot shaming hand shaming
breath shaming
butt shaming and we could continue down
the list of of body parts all of which
have their own dedicated shamers and
also their own dedicated anti-shamers
but at least we could say the shaming is
relegated to external features so far
i'm not aware of any
spleen shamers or kidney shamers
yet despite the exorbitant attention
paid to the problem
i doubt that people are more likely to
make mean comments about your body today
than at any other point in history in
fact it seems quite certain that body
shaming today
is much less common than it once was
after all there was a time when you
could walk outside you know
you put on your sunday's best and head
into town to laugh at obese people and
hairy women
at an event that was literally called a
freak show
we may have our own ways of gawking at
strange physical specimens these days
but we usually do it through
through reality tv and usually it
assumes an ostensibly inspirational or
medical tone
my 600 pound life on tlc for example is
a show about extremely obese people
but it sells itself as an opportunity to
follow participants as we document their
life-saving journey
this is a kinder and gentler approach to
the spectacle for
at least in this sense a kinder and
gentler age
and it's probably the best we can hope
for from a fallen species such as
ourselves
now i'm not saying that nobody is ever
shamed for the way they look i know i i
know they are i am
i read my youtube comments on occasion
you bastards
but if a person is subjected to a
greater quantity of mean comments today
it's only because we interact with so
many more people
and we put ourselves in front of large
audiences all the time
as part of living our half human half
cyborg lives in cyberspace
there's always going to be small petty
jerks who love snickering anonymously
from the sidelines if given the
opportunity
but all the attention they're given only
makes a troll molehill into a mountain
most people whether on the internet or
in three-dimensional space
are not inclined to make any comments
about your physical looks
and most who are inclined will say nice
things and if you are ever subjected to
a genuinely vicious attack
you can always post about it on facebook
and get thousands of people
lining up to assuage your damaged ego
and donate generously to your gofundme
campaign
what we should consider is that maybe
the real epidemic when it comes to body
shaming
and bullying generally is that we
are so unable to deal with it
the interesting question is not why are
all these people saying mean things
but rather why are all these people
incapable of
handling the mean things that are said
to them
we could run around till our faces turn
blue demanding that everybody see
themselves as beautiful just the way
they are but at a certain point
a person has to learn to function in the
world without a constant iv
drip of positive emotional reinforcement
if a bit of taunting from the internet
peanut gallery causes you to plunge into
despair
you probably have issues which the
peanut gallery didn't cause
and which would still exist even if they
all agreed that you're the most
gorgeous specimen in the whole world
there isn't much evidence that people
are any meaner now than they've ever
been at any other point in history
but there is a fair amount of evidence
that we're far more vulnerable
and dependent upon affirmation than at
any other point in history
you know some of the reason for this
shift isn't hard to decipher social
media
intentionally breeds this kind of
fragility and mass codependence
many billions of dollars have been spent
on technology designed
precisely to give you this fragile
emotional complex and many more billions
have been made because of it
now it also should be stated that some
of the things we call body shaming can
come from a place of genuine sincere
concern on the part of the alleged
shamer
you know calling somebody fat and ugly
or stupid is clearly an insult but
these days we're so determined to
eradicate body shaming that even a
medically
accurate and sound statement like
obesity is unhealthy or
you know you shouldn't be proud of being
morbidly overweight
even that is denounced as shaming billy
eilish is obviously not obese so this
doesn't apply in her case but we have
run so far
the other end of the shaming extreme but
now we tell people to embrace and
celebrate aspects of their physical
appearance
that they can change and will kill them
if they don't
so in the end body shaming is not all
it's cracked up to be
if you really feel shame about your body
because some anonymous troll teased you
the problem is less the troll and more
the fact that you care what the troll
thinks in the first place that you are
in fact
desperately in need of affirmation from
that troll
and his withholding of it causes you to
spiral
into emotional crisis that is the
problem
in a sense you are the problem focus on
that
hey you uh yeah you you're right you
right there
hit the subscribe button right now do it
do it right now
i thank you for your compliance it's
somewhat appreciated